so I recently played a rapid game on
mechas.org and I found out after the
game that my opponent also has a twitch
Channel and he streamed and commentated
the whole thing so what I've done for
this video is mashed up both of our
commentaries I was playing fellow
streamer Nate Brady whose rating is just
below 2000 and I think it was a really
instructive game and you'll see the
difference between an international
chess master and a pretty strong amateur
player see kind of what goes through our
minds and I think there's a lot to learn
there's some funny moments as well but I
do hope you enjoy the video and be sure
to check out neat on Twitch and YouTube
links will be in the video description
and enjoy
[Music]
and vegetables I'm not gonna do it
that's awesome
there's bigger priorities in life
let's play G6 mix it up against uh
English oh five or E6 for knife six
G6
there's still some flexibility
I could play a Dutch
I can play a symmetrical English
I'm actually conflicted here
I could play one of these
oh man one of the literal best chess
streamers on the planet
um let's play a Dutch he's playing
against Eric it's kind of a delayed no
I'm just kidding I'll probably go into a
landing ground
oh 66.
and if white plays D4 then we transpose
into Mainline
not the typical Dutch move order
oh the sodium attack
and it's not a fruit or a vegetable that
that's salt
the saltiest opening
I hope he's just as nervous as I am
played yes
D6 there's a
uh wait this isn't uh the standard
Leningrad because white hasn't played D4
White's more playing uh
English
I was reflexively about to play D6
allowing takes and if I take with Bishop
I lose this maybe it's a potential
soccer does he have his heart rate
monitor on is it is his heart rate
spiking because of I'm thinking E5 here
because he's playing me is that is that
happening E5 take
I could also take first
maybe there's some logic to that
taken then like this if I was black I
definitely would have gone into a
Stafford Gambit just to watch him refute
it and destroy me yeah I feel like this
is a pretty rare
move order
there's a rare opening in general
um
I'm starting with 926
and D6
we all decide whether I wanna
the E6 or E5
I think E5 is probably a bit more called
for
like even though it blocks suspicious
in my excitement I'm so thrilled with
this
I just want to have natural development
Bishop E6
D7 King H2 coming
and probably rookie eight
okay so I've essentially tried to
optimize all my pieces
and it's going to be a question what to
do next like we're officially entering
the middle game
I'm not sure which area of the board to
play on
and sometimes it's just a matter of
asking oh what how the position can be
improved
which is why I have any weaknesses here
in D4 but D4 is well controlled
is there any piece that can be I'm okay
with being like a YouTube clip of all an
ambulance but not for me like I'm fine
there's idea of h6g6
and put the parts oh no my queen
I think that is
like looking like he's gonna sack like
trying to sack his Queen I'll just take
so that's the question what white wants
to do oh no my continue improving
history
so
yeah do I want to play H6 King H7
like if I know the next move is Queen D2
I actually gotta tell my wife because
she'll want to go for something like
because she likes Eric too
h6g5
for tick tick
trade a lot
I think I have four benefits me in those
cases
Denzel where have you been all right I'm
gonna go for each six
enabling this or this maybe both moves
Queen C1
I don't fully understand why white
played Queen C1 and not Queen D2
I think I'll go ahead I feel like I'm
playing pretty solid I'm playing pretty
solid right now
yeah I'm not afraid of Moves Like H4
because Knight G4 moves like F4 look a
little bit unsettling
but
in the very least I probably okay now I
don't know what to do now now I'm a
little nervous depending how white takes
like seven or King H7
what happened I travel around a bit weak
why is why is probably timed out oh how
to alternator
I'm doing one definitely please don't
backseat my first kind of normal street
The Right Move
like I love to play this on my own for
sure
I'm okay with getting destroyed I just
want to definitely want to play on my
own
um but I will be streaming the next
couple days there's this worries
that is scary here because I feel like
this is
a little nervous about G4 looking
forward to I'm nervous about everything
here I think just and then Monday
oh it's a cruise decathlon events never
play F3 but play F 360 arena for a
couple hours oh okay cool
yeah I know like Trevor is a lurker
um I don't even like chess but I like
watching your videos
I'll take that as a compliment hopefully
I can make you like chess someday
oh that's funny I always wonder like how
many people
I don't like how many people watch my
videos but I wanted to play on a d file
but I didn't want to move my Rook I'll
be a hands on that file so
this is my thought process here
like Jesus I feel like my queen vicious
battery really isn't wasn't doing much
although it was preventing
G4 from him I guess maybe
Knight G6 I have to watch out for this
idea Rook D1 C5
I think one of light's main ideas in
this position
I'm like kind of I really like
technology
especially compared to a White's setup
with these Pawns
but it's still a bit hard to like crack
it's not clear how I actually expand
because usually the weights make
progress everything's over here right
now and it's not easy to push the pawns
without losing a pawn all right I'm just
gonna keep keep going with my plan and
I have some Defenders over here maybe
Knight g17
calculating Queen F7 F4 probably Knight
G1 because really where else there's a
lot of Trades my Knight's really not
doing much
Queen E7 runs into this move
[Music]
I actually like the
or do I I don't know
like b62 just restricts C5
because I'm realizing Queen F7 is still
met with C5
Eric if you happen to be watching do you
know one of your uh I mean you can't be
yourself
viewers or other viewers are here there
there's this cool King command that you
can do on my stream I think just B6 yeah
you cannot do it
in many other places wasn't my first
consideration King The King command to
change my king on stream
well I'm sure the thoughts coming from
Eric
a lot better than the thoughts coming
from the mountain I really really hope
great writing you like mentioned I don't
know he's probably got a lot of Chatters
in there but can you like I definitely
want to see the commentary from this
game so I'm hoping this is a video I
will take opening requests between games
like before games start I'll look at
Chad and see if there's but
that would be awesome
I thought your title said destructive
chess I'm I'm like I should have it so
distracted here first on the stream I
don't know if I do a lot of constructive
chest streams
but maybe we can have an instructor
destructive chess
okay C5 anyway it's playable I guess I
think I have to take he's not nearly a
Starstruck design that's ridiculous
I would like to that is absurd
all I want from Eric like one time is oh
good move
oh good move like that's all I want just
once
Bishop Z5 queen of seven
uh trying to calculate
like oh that was that was a good move oh
like you know that'd be fine
Asics is the safest move I think I just
play this
I was trying to look at lines where I
allowed I'm gonna raise him right I've
been trying to drop the Bishops so uh
because we usually stop at eight maybe
so I will
side
if white leaves the bishop on C5 though
like then I'll have ideas of being here
might be cool too
I feel like there's no pressure on G5 or
goodness
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna come back over
here
okay the bishop returns
do I have any
like night jump ideas to C5 I'm trying
to like figure out how to make progress
here I wonder
I gotta move quickly too
I need an I need a Frozen
um
I don't think F4 really helps white much
okay I think I'm just gonna add some
more protection over here
um
like I know he's like he can play bullet
you can play Fast Times so I'm not even
ever thinking about
the opportunity to flag him here like
that's never happening
yeah lights kind of
folding up into a ball
kind of like a roly-poly
it's been a long time since I saw a
roly-poly
I have this idea Knight H5 Bishop F6
oh hold what were you doing on his
channel you're supposed to be here
I hope you guys are giving me some love
G4 is always my position is like a
roly-poly
but it's one of those awkward parties
where no one's really interacting with
each other
and kind of just sitting still
being anti-social
oh thank you very much oh my candies
okay so I guess uh the plan is Bishop F6
Knight G7 I wonder if I can essentially
rearranging it I was pushing I didn't
even want to attempt this before because
the Rooks could just double up and then
his Pawn is made
Queen G3
then it'll be a question if I need to
take time to defend it I have Bishop C8
here
there's A5 I think I'll play Bishop C8
the bishop still has influence on the
king side
Harding on the king's side until the
cows come home
I'm not sure where the cows are in this
position
because Bishop has one sad legal move
a lot of White's pieces are stuck which
is probably a good sign
ooh okay so there's this idea now I have
this move
so there's two Outpost squares for my
Knights
F4 and H4
there's also ideas of eventually playing
each five
I'll start with this
I think very likely it will be a trail
on F5
I probably want to take with Bishop
the knights are more effective in this
position
wow
Bishop H1
I was thinking about putting my my
knight here but now I'm I'm too worried
to do that
I think this one oh my goodness this
game this game
so that way I free up the movement of
The Rook
gradually I want to prepare H5
the king is very stuck here I just want
to check okay now I feel like this
Knight
Bishops
okay I'll probably take with this Pawn
although
uh
yeah I probably did with this phone
okay now this bishop is stuck forever
banana five
what a funny position so now if he takes
here we could trade oh I don't know if
you probably wouldn't take it this night
is I'm not sure if I want to take with
bishop or is he really doing anything is
this Knight really doing anything
wow there's a really funny line what's
up zaku look who I'm playing
you work though
I've confused him that's amazing that's
all I wanted
all right let's open the center a little
bit that's all I wanted
that's all I've wanted in life there's a
funny line where I put my Bishop here
sac and then F3 checkmate
but
it's just a far-off fantasy
I'm feeling good here because position
is a bit more open and the Bishops
usually like open positions
the position is not open for this bishop
yeah very strange this Knight is
terrible now I just I don't know what to
do anymore
I don't know what to do I'll bring my
I'll tell you my it's the only open fire
okay
and this prevents 92 which was only
legal night move in order to get the
Knight out of here I have to
those White's trying to fight with a
rookie too
I guess now it makes sense to play H5
tension now
now wow so now I can take
and I haven't won any material in the
position it looks very good
rookie two I'll play Bishop E5
just avoiding the trade I want to win
this Pawn
also aligning with the King
like there's ideas of G4 now
G4 takes takes takes check
the pawn
oh
I'm just gonna argue that there's
nothing over there
I'm just gonna argue this for a minute
but there's no it's still covering these
uh these pawns I'm not facing any issues
it feels closer now
tick there
let's play this idea Queen G3 oh no oh
no what do I do about this
I think if I come back here and here I
can oh no I hung my Rook oh that's a
free room no no I hung my Rook
ah
ah it's still a funny position
I think White's really still
in the ball
um
let's go for the double up and then
probably take on each three oh no
some eventual Bishop made in the end
ggs
it took a long time to make progress in
the king's side
uh let's let's starting from the middle
game I think all of that started with
the move Pawn H6 one small step for a a
pawn but one giant leap for the eventual
Pawn storm